quelques conseils pour se placer sur
scène le chanteur barcella partage son
expérience auprès des enfants des
conseils bienvenue pour ces jeunes
élèves qui viennent des quatre coins de
la haute-saône et qu'ils vont vivre une
drôle et chouette expérience musicale
on apprend des choses pour faire un
spectacle la fin de l'année en mai avec
l'artiste barre cela j'aime bien le
champ je fais du solfège épais bas
j'aime bien chanter avec surtout dans un
ensemble
[Applaudissements]
des enfants heureux de participer à
cette aventure qui a commencé il ya
quelques mois avec des rencontres dans
les écoles pour apprendre et découvrir
les chansons de l'artiste
je parcours à peu près toute la haute
saône donc je vais jusqu'à revanche en
voilà pas mal autour de vesoul et donc
je travaille et que les enfants depuis
le mois d'octobre donc voilà ça fait une
bonne vingtaine de séances dans l'année
je les vois alors des fois que la
séparait des fois que l'as ensemble et
on travaille ses chances moment là
l'univers de barcella les enfants le
connaissent par coeur et barcella et
vesoul c'est une histoire qui remonte à
quelques années quand il avait gagné le
concours jeunes talents du festival
jacques boyd la jeunesse insouciante à
chanter un peu moins les textes que j'ai
fabriqué autour d'un café dans ma
cuisine ça me touche profondément
et puis ce sont les enfants des gens qui
venaient me voir et à presque 10 ans
maintenant donc c'est aussi
générationnel d'avoir comme ça les
familles sur plusieurs générations
et voilà plaisir
les répétitions vont se poursuivre sans
barcella il reviendra fin mai pour un
grand concert avec les enfants au
théâtre edwige feuillère à venir
[Musique]